today he advises presidents he's part of
the inspiration behind Ironman and he's
worth billions of dollars but Elon Musk
dreams started when he made a really
important decision as a 12 year old boy
in South Africa it was 1983 and the 12
year old Elon Musk decided that he
wanted to be a computer programmer the
problem was in 1983 there weren't any
classes for 12 year olds wanted to learn
how to code he didn't let that hold them
back because he made that decision and
so he caught himself and he quickly had
a computer game called blastaar which
was a space fighting game that he wrote
and eventually sold for $500 mission
accomplished
Elon must then made another really
important decision he decided he wanted
to be an entrepreneur in America the
problem was he was in South Africa and
it was hard to get the visa to go from
South Africa to United States his mom
was Canadian so he went to Canada and at
age 17 became a Canadian citizen he went
to college in Canada he quickly
transferred to the US as soon as he
could again his goal what he decided was
he was going to be an entrepreneur in
America he ended up at Stanford but
since his goal wasn't to become a
student he dropped out to start his
first company his first company was
called zip tube
that he started with his brother and it
was an online city guide for the
publishing industry he signed up the New
York Times at Chicago Tribune and he
eventually built it up and sold it in
the deal he ended up getting 22 million
dollars his goal what he decided was to
become an American entrepreneur another
mission accomplished
now he wanted to do something bigger
right he's 28 years old he's got 22
million dollars he didn't just want to
sit on that he decided he wanted to do
something bigger and more important so
we started XCOM it was a financial
services company that eventually merged
and became PayPal with Elon Musk being
the single largest shareholder in PayPal
eBay then bought them out for 1.5
billion dollars making Elon Musk
yeah 165 million dollars from that deal
next mission accomplished now you want
to do something bigger his decision was
I'm not just going to sit on this I want
to do something bigger I want to do so
this is going to change the world so he
launched Tesla to make electric cars and
he launched SpaceX to go and explore
space and it's not just about putting a
man in space he wants life to be
multiplanetary that's his decision he
decided that life should be
multiplanetary and he's not going to
stop until that happens he wants people
living on other planets see the key
thing along Elon Musk entire life is
that he decided when he wanted something
he decided and he made it happen
and he didn't listen to the voices
inside his head or everybody tell him
that he was crazy he didn't listen to
the people who would say that you don't
have the resources you don't have the
technology you don't have the
capabilities you don't have the
connections he decided that this was
going to happen and he would not accept
any other alternative you need to do the
same with your business and your goals
we all have dreams we all have
aspirations we all have ambitions we all
have goals that we want to accomplish
and yet how often you go out and
accomplish those big dreams the reason
you're not where you want to be is
because you haven't truly decided is
because you've created an environment
that holds you where you are because you
listen to the little man you listen to
the people in your life who tell you why
you can't do it you listen to that voice
in your head that tells you that you're
not good enough that you could never go
out and do this and you may have moments
of bravery that make you want to step
out and make you start to believe in
yourself and then BAM life smacks you
back down until you truly decide and
accept no other alternative
then you won't really achieve your big
dreams and your goals but if you do if
you decide who you're going to be who
you're going to be surrounded by where
you're going to be what your business is
going to look like if you truly decide
and you really feel that and you accept
no other alternative
then you can make your dreams become a
reality and who knows it might make you
a billionaire to believe if you guys
like this video you want to see more
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon
every week I share inspiring and
motivational stories that really mean
something to me that I hope you'll check
out in my newsletter below
you